okay one more tour through the
Evangelical televangelist Insanity
throughout the pandemic televangelist
Kenneth Copeland has been coming up with
all sorts of bizarre Rants and Raves
about curing the pandemic this way that
the vaccines are bad all these different
things
this is a very weird clip where he
screams in order to kill the virus in
his colon he's talking about the flu
virus not I mean when you say in the
colon are we talking about viral
gastroenteritis it doesn't seem like it
take a look at this and by the way at
the bottom of the screen if you need him
to pray for you there's a number you can
call
I'm gonna help you here with something
yeah
in the name of Jesus
flu virus
died
in my colon
now
[Applause]
if Saturday Night Live which I don't
really find funny anymore was going to
parody this
how could they do it he's actually up
there saying die in my colon and the
congregation repeats die in my colon how
how do you make a joke how do you
satirize that it's impossible and the
important message here is that we should
all remember Kenneth Copeland's entire
grift is tax exempt because it's a
church his six plus million dollar house
where he lives with his wife Gloria
is exempt from property taxes how well
it's listed as a parsonage a parsonage
is a church house provided for a member
of the clergy sometimes you know like
the old Catholic Church down the street
has a parsonage and it's often sort of
like a very modest Department of some
kind his six million dollar house is tax
exempt from real estate taxes because
it's a parsonage he tried to get
tax-exempt status for his private jet
that was denied but he still has a
private jet it just not tax exempt and
taxing churches would generate about 71
billion dollars per year if the United
States were to do that so that's Kenneth
Copeland
if you said behind the scenes hey I'm
gonna look at how look at how sheep uh
how much of a of a group of flock of
sheep I have out there I'm gonna go out
there and say die in my colon and
they're all gonna chant it with me it
seems like a joke it seems like a joke
but it's unfortunately very very real